nous avons rencontré Jeannie à ton rouge
chez elle son centre de ressourcement
ouvert avec l'aide de son mari de ses
quatre enfants Nanny un hôtel ni une
chambre d'hôtes un peu des deux à la
fois mais c'est surtout un concept
unique d'accueil de 8 chambres
personnalisées dans un décor raffiné et
des conditions optimales pour un séjour
de récupération de calme de détente de
sérénité et de joie du partage de son
coup de foudre pour la Réunion pour la
saison à la construction pas à pas de ce
petit coin charmant et original cette
retraité de l'éducation nationale nous
emmène faire le tour de la christophine
sa propriété touristique pas tout à fait
comme les autres
nous avions de multiples talents dans la
famille et lorsque donc je suis arrivée
ici c'était très beau j'ai pensé que ça
pouvait être justement 800 mètres
d'altitude
les gens respirent ça se passe bien
d'autre part bon ben il y avait ce
verger
la nature vraiment et je me suis dit bon
ben allons faire quelque chose et allons
offrir cette prestation là aux personnes
parce que bon je pense qu'ici il y avait
vraiment rien de de cette de cet ordre
là bon il y a si la hausse évidemment
mais si la hausse c'est pas la même ici
il y a rien de médical ici c'est juste
de la de la détente on est on est bien
on est tranquille et puis voilà quoi
c'est sans prétention
il y a pas de
désir de
les gens se retapent quoi
de l'extérieur qui viennent aussi
quelquefois mais justement
également curieusement ces bouche à
oreille aussi c'est à dire que c'est des
personnes qui sont reparties en
métropole par exemple et qui en parlait
à des amis et alors à ce moment-là ils
viennent à la Réunion et ils passent un
petit un petit séjour à la christophine
on a eu des anglais on a eu des Suisses
quand même bon évidemment ne refuse pas
les personnes qui ont envie de rester là
je vais pas les touristes on les accepte
et avec grande joie avec grand plaisir
mais disons que c'est vrai que je
préfère et que nous préférons
accueillir des personnes qui sont
vraiment de l'île de la Réunion quoi
voilà c'est pas par hasard qui s'appelle
la christophine ah non c'est pas par
hasard parce que la christophine ça veut
dire enfin ça veut dire c'est chouchou
hein c'est le alors bon il y avait
beaucoup de chouchous sur le terrain
quand on est arrivé la première fois et
donc on a pensé au chouchou mais
chouchou c'est pas très joli donc on a
préféré christophine qui sonne mieux
puis bon Saint Christophe c'est le
patron des voyageurs donc pour
accueillir ici les personnes ça nous
semblait vraiment quelque chose donc
christophine bon il y a aussi mon fils
qui aime beaucoup les cristaux
donc cristaux fine ça faisait penser un
petit peu aussi à cristaux
qui fait que ben on a gardé christophine
on a trouvé que ça sonnait bien voilà
comme vous allez pouvoir le voir c'est
un petit établissement ce n'est pas
véritablement bon bien que ça ça ait les
comment dirais-je les prestations
nécessaires pour mériter les deux
étoiles ce n'est quand même pas
l'hôtel classique quoi ça n'a rien à
voir avec avec ce que on attend de
l'hôtellerie quoi
est-ce que le client lui dans les
prestations il a droit une alimentation
particulière disons que on cuisine
plutôt
enfin un peu un peu diététique
c'est-à-dire on essaye de faire léger de
ne pas avoir de sauce grasse des choses
lourdes légers mais disons que
Dominique qui s'occupe la cuisine il
invente tout le temps c'est jamais deux
fois la même chose et bon on a vraiment
un repas assez complet assez équilibré
mais non on n'est pas ni bio ni Macrobio
non nous sommes nous mangeons un peu de
tout et ce qui a aussi c'est que bon si
on a des personnes qui sont vraiment
végétariennes à ce moment là on s'adapte
il suffit de nous téléphoner
quelques jours avant
pour nous dire ben moi par exemple je
n'aime pas la viande je préfère le
poisson donc à ce moment là Dominique va
inventer mais alors une heure avant il
sait pas ce qu'il va faire à manger ce
qui m'oblige moi à avoir une grande
réserve de dans les frigos parce que
sinon dans les Hauts ici c'est vrai
qu'on ne trouve pas forcément
tout ce dont on a besoin quoi mais on
prévoit et puis on arrive j'espère pour
jusqu'à maintenant personne ne sait
plaint
on arrive à satisfaire les clients et
puis bon on n'a pas voulu faire des
repas du style créole non plus parce que
bon ben c'est pas la vocation non plus
c'est très bien fait dans les dans les
champs les tables d'hôtes et l'Égypte
ici donc on n'allait pas faire en double
emploi quoi est-ce que le centre a une
particularité une particularité je crois
la convivialité
on essaie d'être vraiment en harmonie
avec les personnes qui sont là et
c'est ça la particularité du centre mais
on peut dire aussi que vous partagez
votre propre vie de famille avec
absolument rien absolument parce que
nous sommes nous habitons dans la même
nous avons notre chambre la chambre des
filles et nous sommes là
nous vivons dans la dans le centre quoi
d'accord au centre du centre très bien
là comme ça c'est notre chambre le décor
pour vous a une très grande place
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les couleurs
bon là on a le blanc et l'or j'adore la
lumière et l'or c'est la lumière le
blanc également donc là j'ai vraiment
travaillé et ça ce sont mes couleurs
c'est ce que j'aime donc pour cette
chambre là je me suis réservée le blanc
et or dans l'entrée on a pu voir aussi
que c'était blanc et or parce que c'est
c'est ce qui permet aussi au nom de se
détendre la par cette lumière et d'être
très très
tout de suite quand on rentre on ressent
il y a tout de suite cette décontraction
qui qui saisit
est-ce que vous pensez avoir des remèdes
aux agressions extérieures
oui alors remets d'État bien grand mot
parce que ici n'est pas question de
guérison voilà il est uniquement
question de prévention justement c'est à
dire que de faire que les gens se
sentent bien et donc se sentant bien
c'est vrai que il y a malgré tout bien
que nous soyons une île tropicale ici
pas mal de facteurs de stress de
facteurs de de tension et oui c'est
certain que bon lorsque les personnes
viennent faire une séance de relaxation
sophrologique enfin de type sophrologie
je dis bien parce que ce n'est pas
uniquement de la relaxation
sophrologique c'est la relaxation
profonde en alpha et on a aussi le
jacuzzi alors ça le jacuzzi c'est super
parce que ça s'amasse en profondeur
ici c'est une chambre comme vous pouvez
le voir
à 2 lits voilà tout à l'heure on a vu
une
et voilà le genre de de petites chambres
que nous proposons donc pour les
personnes qui viennent
à deux mais amis ou les choses comme ça
ici on a fait un petit dortoir parce que
quelquefois il y a des amis qui viennent
en petite randonnée ou des cheveux quand
ils redescendent ils dorment là il se
reposent ils en profite pour prendre un
petit jacuzzi comme on prend ce qu'on
veut c'est à la carte on fait ce qu'on
veut et là on a fait une petite salle de
bain voilà et bon on essaye de ou quand
il y a des petites familles des en
général bon les enfants j'adore les
enfants parce que j'ai toujours
travaillé toute ma vie avec des enfants
donc pour moi les enfants c'est sacré
mais c'est vrai que venir ici avec les
enfants c'est pas très conseillé non
plus est-ce que c'est à la portée de
n'importe quel budget de venir faire un
séjour chez vous alors
sur les prix nous avons été aussi
notre c'est dans notre philosophie donc
cherchons pas donc particulièrement à
faire rentrer des finances et par
conséquent nous cherchons à faire
plaisir aux personnes
nous faisons surtout justement des des
comment dirais-je des packaging
donc et nous avons une prestation
globale si possible ce qui fait que les
prix si on regarde chaque prix c'est pas
très cher pour pouvoir permettre aux
gens de d'avoir un maximum de
prestations et de choix voilà on peut
citer juste un exemple fauteuil que nous
avons vu tout à l'heure c'est 50 francs
pour trois quarts d'heure quoi donc
c'est pas excessif mais seulement bon
évidemment quand on cumule quand on
prend un fauteuil un jacuzzi une
relaxation et aussi bon ben c'est vrai
que ça finit par faire une certaine
somme mais bon justement c'est pour
permettre aux personnes de maximum de
personnes de pouvoir bénéficier des
prestations ici
enracinement
ensuite on prend
mon de doucement le cerceau devant en
inspire
pousse vers
le haut homme n'est plus peur n'est plus
peur et éclaire le profond de ton cœur
observe le sacré se crée de ta mémoire
secrète ouvre l'oeil et traverse le plan
du miroir les plus peur
éclaire le profond de ton corps car
l'envers de la vie n'est nullement la
mort
éclaire éclaire tout jusqu'au fond de
ton âme et sur tes ombres troubles
élèvent cette flamme qui danse avec ta
peur les plus peur de ta peur toute nuit
a toujours les toiles pour lueur le noir
à sa lumière qui dévoile l'erreur laisse
monter tes pleurs écrit
et pleure entre dedans de toi et refait
le chemin soit l'enfant qui renaît du
noir vers la lumière cesse de tout
prévoir laisse venir demain sois vivant
et respire inspire ton présent expire
ton passé expire ton hier
laisse s'ouvrir les vannes et
s'engouffrer les os au fil de tes canaux
laisse le flux vivant librement
s'écouler et rouler chaque flot
respire à plein poumons que tes cellules
vibrent lèvent le voile obscur et
désormais soit libre